i'm gonna probably get really red during
this because it's embarrassing
so i was with my then boyfriend and
my best friend and her husband and we
traveled
to morocco together then my then
boyfriend got sick
so he decided that he was just gonna
chill in the room for the day and try
and like get over this random bug that
he had
me and christina my best friend and her
husband ben were like okay well we're
just gonna like go out and go shopping
we really wanted to get one of those
moroccan wedding blankets like we'll
just be like an hour
or two we'll be right back left him with
like a little bit of water
so the rooms at the riyadh you locked
them with like an actual padlock from
the outside
so that's like when you left for the day
that's like what you did and then you
could also lock them from the inside i
think i thought i was like locking him
in like to be safe but like i didn't
think about the fact that he wouldn't
build to get out so i
locked him in the room it was fine for a
little because he was sleeping there's
ac in the room so he was just like
passed out but then he woke up like an
hour or two later
we weren't back and this was 2014 so
like
we had cell phones but when you traveled
it wasn't like
the norm to turn your data on because it
was much more expensive and there were
not phones in the room
he waited for a while he like finished
the water that i
left for him and then me and christina
and ben
ended up like shopping for a lot longer
than we initially planned and then
we got back to the riyadh and there's
this beautiful pool
and it's hot out so we're like let's
just put our feet in the pool and chill
for
a little and then this other couple came
also to the pool of the riyadh and
started talking to us we ended up
talking with them until one o'clock in
the morning
and chris was locked in the room the
entire time
and the worst part is he could hear us
downstairs like
laughing and talking but we couldn't
hear him
so he was like ready to murder me when i
got back to the room
he didn't have food he had run out of
water he was just like
trapped in this room but apparently he
was like
knocking on the door and like kind of
trying to yell to get our attention and
we never heard a thing he was texting us
because he had wi-fi in the room so like
his phone worked but i
didn't have it out with me i mean he
survived
he was fine and then actually the next
morning he was
not sick anymore like it was like a
24-hour bug and so then he was fine
after that
so maybe being locked in the room helped
cure him
but he still married me so he forgave me
five years ago i was with my boyfriend
we were together for about
two years and his birthday was coming up
i planned a weekend for us to go away in
canada so i saved up money for like
months to do like the rental car because
we were gonna drive up i remember i'd
gotten like a really great deal on a
hotel and i was like so excited because
it was saving me a lot of money we drive
up and we get to the hotel
and he goes to park the car and i was
like all right let me go like check us
in because i'd gotten like a bottle of
champagne and stuff like that to like
celebrate and so i get up to the hotel
and i tell them my name
and so excited and they're like we can't
find a reservation and i was like
well that's weird i was like all right
maybe my last name has a space so i was
like all right maybe it's
the space or whatever so give them my id
still can't find the reservation so i
got pissed and i started
saying like what are you talking about
like how can you not find the
reservation i'm showing them you know
these are the dates i booked it months
ago like they look at the email they're
like yeah you totally you booked it but
that was for last weekend
i was like oh no so i basically had just
taken
hundreds of dollars and set them on fire
because now the hotel wasn't gonna work
with me because they were like
this screaming lady we're not gonna help
you we're not gonna do anything
different
i get a text from my boyfriend at the
time saying like hey can't find a spot
looking in another parking lot whatever
and i'm like all right i got to figure
out what i'm going to do right now
so i wound up paying a full price
for the right weekend and i just booked
it on my credit card before my boyfriend
even found out and so it wound up being
like
almost a thousand dollars and i don't
think i ever even told him
i think i just made it seem like yeah
we're good this everything's fine ever
since then
i check everything about four different
times
i add it into my calendar i make sure
that everything lines up i keep a
planner
just because i'm so scared that this is
gonna happen again three years ago
i went to europe for the first time i
went to paris
with my friend i was single at the time
i
really wanted to meet a french man
because duh
like of course that accent i
hopped on grindr like one does and i
found a gentleman who was willing to
rendezvous with me this so happened to
be
in the dead of night i went to this
gentleman's apartment
he seemed perfectly nice but there was
definitely a language barrier there i
also learned when i got there that all
of his roommates were home and asleep he
was like
we just have to stay in the living room
and we have to stay completely quiet and
we can't turn any lights on and i was
like
okay um yeah i guess that's what we're
doing guess we got to make that work
kind of figuring things out in the dark
it was
very quick and then i was like well i
guess we're done now so
i'm gonna i'm gonna leave he didn't
really feel like walking me out so i
went on my merry way i got down to the
lobby
and i was ready to push on the door to
exit to the street
and the door wouldn't open that's weird
try again
i'm like pulling it and pushing it i'm
so close to being outside but i'm not
able to get there
and then i turn back around and i try to
get back
up to the apartment uh through the other
door of the lobby and that one is locked
too so
i'm trapped in the foyer i'm like oh
this is how i die
i'm in a foreign country my phone is
like not really gonna work that well all
of my friends are asleep i
looked around the whole lobby i found a
button
on the opposite wall and i was like i
guess i can try this
i go over there and i push the button
and that's what releases the
door and i'm like this is not up to fire
code safety so i finally get out
and then at this point it's 2 am there's
like drunk french people everywhere
being kind of rowdy
i get home to my bed safely and i live
to tell the tale i got my wish i got to
rendezvous with a frenchman it did not
go down exactly how i pictured
but that's life that's just life for you
[Music]
you